this is crazy Ryan Reynolds was in South
America and he was doing like a you know
press junket hundreds of rabid fans were
so excited to see him they pushed the
crowd control barrier and it collapsed
Ryan Reynolds had to jump out of the way
check this out it's crazy there they are
they push
yeah he jumped right up yeah I'm glad
he's okay yeah yeah and I might just
bring this up because a lot of times
people don't know what it's like to be
someone like Ryan Reynolds you know to
be in that kind of position it can be
scary so a lot of people think oh being
like a huge star like that must be all
fun and games it's not it can be very
very scary and something just like that
happened to me this morning yeah it did
and I don't know why that's funny it's
just it was it was scary and it was
frightening and it was the same kind of
intensity and we actually have tape of
it can you roll that please Oh Jocelyn
Don yeah if you lean on it it kind of
jostles a little bit yeah you got to
watch out for that you want TV yeah I'm
on TV
yeah what you know Conan O'Brien
what show you want it's called Conan so
you were the show that's me that they
named the show after me and i'ma show
after you yeah about you it's like a
talk show it's been on for I've been on
the air for like 26 years really yeah
cool I gotta I gotta go do the show yeah
they're still doing it
I could have been killed
I'm sorry that's my agent okay he looks
familiar